- On this episode, we talk about freelance
to full time,
what I do when I'm traveling,
and Meerkat and Periscope.
What wins on those things.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(hip hop music)
I love this idea of like color,
it's the show, black and white, it's not.
Cool.
- [DRock] Can we start it like this?
(mumbles)
- They can see this?
This is how it went down?
- [DRock] Yup.
- Like this is in it?
100%.
All right.
Hey everyone.
Just going to hand this off.
No trimming, I'm just going...
Until I shave it outright,
it's just going to be angry.
(laughter)
(grumbles)
- [DRock] You got that?
- [India] No.
(mumbles)
- All right.
- [India] 88
- 88?
Ready?
- [Staphon] Yup.
- What's up everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 88
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
88, a great number for me
because I'm a huge fan of Al Toon.
One of my favorite players of all time.
Probably my favorite Jet of all time.
Like, push comes to shove,
I think I would go with Al Toon number 88
of the New York Jets.
Just a smooth wide receiver that I enjoyed
in my heyday of my youthful Jets watching.
Getting excited for football.
Have decided I'm going to the NFL draft
and that gives me a solid opportunity,
I would say a high
probability of being the face
of the Jets draft pick because
this is in Chicago now,
there won't be a lot of
people wearing Jets jerseys,
like normally New York,
I and AJ will be doing that
and so look for me on NFL network
at ESPN.com on draft day
because I fully expect
to make an appearance
and we'll see how I react to
the sixth pick of the draft.
Excited about the show,
India was sick yesterday,
she's feeling slightly better,
I appreciate the hustle
of working through that
and not being soft India and
staying at home another day.
Little bit of switch-a-roo.
Staphon show DRock.
DRock not behind the camera.
Is this a training in process?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- In case you ever got sick.
Yes, I like that.
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Jeanluc asks,
"This questions really
"got me thinking.
"When do you shift from
hiring a freelancer
"to hiring someone for full time?"
- Jeanluc, easy question.
It's just easy.
There's really a couple of scenarios.
Number one, the moment
you fall in love with them
and you say you should
join my team full time
because we're going to be great together,
this well bring value to my business.
Number two, when you have a necessity.
When you're business is growing,
whether it's a new
client or you're selling
more of your stuff that
they're producing for
or whatever it may be.
Your business has grown
and now you have a tested employee
that goes to full time.
There's a third scenario when
the freelancer is so infatuated with love
with your business that
they're pushing aggressively
to join the team.
It may not be practical,
you may not be able
to fully afford it, but
your intuition tells you
that long term, you know
nine months from now,
the ROI will start kicking in
and I want to reward this
person's passion around me
so I'm willing to make a little
less money in the short term
for that relationship and that
stickiness of the long game.
Those tend to be the
scenarios when you make
the shift, Jeanluc.
- [Voiceover] Zack asks, "What's
your travel schedule like
"to and from the office?
"Car, train, Uber, walk?
"And how do you spend that time?"
- Travis?
- [India] No Zack.
- Zack, I just thought Travis
because of Uber probably.
- [India] Oh.
- Zack?
- [India] Zack.
- Zack,
I live on the Upper East Side.
Our office is on 24th and Park,
so on the East Side it's
a straight shoot down
from Park Avenue, that is 90% of the time
my move in the morning,
then I obviously travel a lot.
So a lot of the time it's to JFK
or things of that nature.
It's always an Uber or Black Car
or taxi, so it's usually in car.
I'm sitting the back, seat belt on.
Safety first, what?
I don't even know why I did hashtag there.
(chuckles)
Safety first, what?
(chuckles) Fuck.
(laughs)
That is ridiculous.
I call my mom, call
Brandon, check my e-mail,
check my Twitter.
Look through my Instagram.
That's really what I'm usually doing.
It's usually mom or Brandon.
Brandon who runs Wine Library,
to catch up on the day,
strategize a little bit.
Checking e-mail, checking Twitter,
looking through Instagram a little bit.
Now, right now, checking
my fantasy baseball team
and the news around fantasy baseball.
And then moments in time right?
Where check my Nuzzel for news,
and, you know, maybe
in seven or eight days
I'll start checking the NFL draft news
that will go away,
then I'll get into training camp news.
But for the most part,
I'm fully in mom, Brandon,
sprinkle in my sister there a little bit,
but my sister and dad come
more ad hoc during the day.
That's kind of how I do it.
- [Voiceover] Brian asks,
"Gary, did you catch
"the Wired story on Walt Disney World's
Billion Dollar Magic Band?
"How do you see this space evolving?
"What do you think about
the necessity for these
"online/offline bridge technologies?"
- Brian, I mean you
know the answer, right?
Like this is an interesting question
because this is inevitable.
Smart technology is
going to eat up the world
everything in the world will be smart.
All of it.
Your shirt, your pants, your underwear,
your sneakers, your socks, the wearables.
It's all coming over the
next 10, 20, 30 years.
It allows things that are physical
to go so much further
in the digital world.
The layering that,
and the ammo that this gives Disney
and that upfront investment
is extraordinary.
The recall, the content pushing out,
the unlocking virtual things,
all of a sudden now they can change
the flow of the park.
One of the things I'm
fascinated by as a retailer
and I thing that I don't
think a lot of people
think about is efficiencies in an airport
or an amusement park,
or a retail store where you
know there's congested area
around Splash Mountain, but
you know there's other parts
of the park where people aren't going.
Well now imagine slapping some technology
on a rock all the way in left
field around the Haunted House
where that's the last
piece of the band touching
for you to unlock the thing
no you're moving people there,
less lines, less lines in front of food.
All of a sudden people are buying an extra
fourth of a hot dog on average.
Got it?
These are really fascinating
business dynamics
that I think will play out
for Disney specifically,
as for the rest of the space.
Hey man, I mean, the Apple Watch
is going to be a game changer
for one, whether it's successful or not.
From what I've read, and
I have one on pre-order,
this buzzing on your body,
which is saving you time
from looking at your phone,
you know what I think about time,
is super fascinating, it's going to start,
if it clicks the way the smart phone did,
you'll start having
people that scale with it.
It's going to be the next smart thing
that kind of happened, the watch.
It's just all coming.
You're properly looking
at it for your business.
Everybody should be looking
at it for their business
if they produce stuff
and it's a space that I'm
spending a lot of time
looking at Vayner/RSE
for our investments
because it's clearly in the way that
social networks and the
maturity of the internet
felt right to me in 2005, 6, and 7,
wearable, smart, technology
being infiltrated
into everything we do.
This cup from India telling India that
the coffee is getting...
Coffee.
The coffee is getting cold
and drink up kiddo.
It's fascinating, it's all fascinating.
- [DRock] When can
we get the smart beard?
- Smart beard is coming soon.
(laughter)
It's telling you to shave.
Trim your shit dick!
Gary's beard's going to say,
"Trim me!
"Trim your shit, mother (beep)!"
- [Voiceover] Jane asks, "Many
of your jabs and right hooks
"reach your b2c audience.
"Wine and books for example.
"But how does it impact b2b?"
- Jane, my right hooks
are not made for b2b,
so you'll never see me Tweet,
"Hey, if you have a business,
"I want your business at VaynerMedia."
It's just not feasible for me,
but my jabs do.
My content, where I talk
about my thought leadership
or my ambition to be a thought leader,
or my hope that I'm a thought leader.
You know, the more I say
things that are right.
You know, somebody watching
or listening right now,
#AskGaryVee episode 88,
I say something about smart
technology that makes them say,
yeah, they need that for their business.
Hey Gary clearly seems to
be paying attention to this
maybe I should talk to Vayner about doing
some activations around it.
We have clearly benefited as an agency
from my outward content as a gateway drug
to RFPs or out and out
handed the business.
So VaynerMedia has clearly
benefited from all of this
and you know, this is something
I'm very passionate about
for all of you that are
watching and listening.
It's super important to
me for you to realize
that you're always one
great piece of content
away from having your life change.
Let's just understand what I mean by this.
It's no different than
being an artist with a song.
Everybody you know started
off not being known
and then had a song
that changed their life.
Every investor you've
heard of that has done well
and made lots of money had an investment,
Twitter,
that changed their lives.
Content, though not to the
level of Madonna or Chris Sacca,
right?
Content has the potential
to change your life.
So if you love something,
music, photography, running
culture, diet culture,
museum culture, like whatever you love,
you have to understand,
by talking to the world.
Even if one person's listening,
all you need is that person to share it,
the pipes of social
network get into motion,
this is why I love Medium,
Medium will hand pick
content from nobody's,
not big followers, just
a good piece of content
and that becomes your
one piece of content away
from what you want to happen happening.
Now here's the problem,
most of you are not good enough
to make that content,
and I get it, that was rough,
and I'm like, and I apologize,
but talent matters, right?
Like baseball players that
get discovered in Japan
that come over to the US
and make lots of money.
They had to be good
enough to be discovered.
You know, the quality of the content
you put out matters.
Like you can't just be
like, museums are nice.
That's not going to lead to
you being the CEO of a museum.
Do you understand?
You got to be right.
When I got out and put out content
that says Instagram's going
to get bought by Facebook
and then everybody says I'm an idiot
and then it happens, I'm not an idiot.
Get it?
So, you know, the things, the
pressure I put upon myself
to answer these five questions
on every episode is these are historic.
We're going to look back at that
and if I'm like, wearable
technologies have no chance
it's a fad and then it happens, idiot.
That wasn't my piece
of content that took me
to the next level.
It was a piece of content
that took me a step back.
So recognize that we have the opportunity
to win this game.
Recognize the quality of what we say,
what we produce how we put it out there
is the variable to that outside.
- [Voiceover] John asks,
"Which industries do you think
"will leverage Meerkat the best?
"Who is their target user?
"What do you think Gary?"
- So John, throwing
Periscope in there as well,
Meerkat and Periscope will be
leveraged by a lot of people
but I actually think retail man.
I think QVC like opportunities on Meerkat.
Like, we're Meerkating right now.
How many people on? 200?
- [DRock] 275.
- 275.
You know, I can schedule a Meerkat,
and I'm planning on doing this by the way,
in a couple of months,
maybe a couple weeks,
where I'm going to say
from 6 PM to 9 PM Eastern.
I'm going to do a QVC-like wine show.
Where I'm just going to
sit here and taste wine
and somebody, DRock, on the other end
is going to be like,
"This person asked this,
"this person asked this."
Like we're literally
going to do a live QVC.
I think retail, selling stuff on live
is very real to me.
I'm a big believer in it.
Imagine I'm Meerkating,
then I'm Tweeting or Facebooking links
to the things I'm talking about.
People are interacting, sharing the links.
It's just super fascinating to me.
So, my big bet is that retail
will be able
to take big advantages of
it because it's the people
that can really take advantage
of what this is replicating.
The reason I do well with business
is I realize nothing really changes,
things just evolve.
Meaning, Meerkat and Periscope
are just live television.
What does well?
QVC.
What else does well?
Entertainment.
So that means that someone can start
an entertainment show.
What else does well?
Sports.
So, I could see a local
minor league baseball team
or you know, like there's just,
sports does well right?
So like, you could start a Frisbee league
that you get people into by watching it
and then sponsors will pay you.
Backyard basketball leagues.
You know the fighting that...
The hardcore fighting
that you see on YouTube
that gets me into the rabbit...
I mean, I waste no time on anything
and even I once and a while
get suckered into like
street fighting on YouTube
because the knockout is just so intense.
You know, I would watch that on Meerkat.
I would watch that on Meerkat right now.
Like if two dudes want to raise their hand
and fight,
two chicks, you know, whatever.
Fight!
I'll watch that shit.
I mean, I'll pay 2.99 to watch it live.
So I think that anything
that's live on television,
Periscope and Meerkat have
the chance to play in,
that's where I see the upside.
(mumbles)
That's it?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Oh great!
That was a good show, solid show,
solid answers.
That's good.
Question of the day.
I want to break it up into two parts.
One, would you televise anything
on Meerkat and Periscope consistently
and two, how much time in a 24 hour day
would you allocate to
watching something live
on one of those platforms?
Fascinating stuff.
Really, really interesting.
By the way, on the record,
even though I'm big investor in Meerkat,
on the record, still
convinced, in my body,
at this moment right now,
that live streaming is a
very challenging sector
and, you know, in the
bait of who's going to win
between Meerkat and Periscope
and I know I wrote about this
but I'm going to say
it again for the show.
You know, neither feels
equally as possible
as one or the other and I still
think that damn ghost in LA,
Snapchat, is a wildcard
in this entire game.
So, you keep asking questions,
I will keep answering them,
with my beard.
People focus on too many small details,
way too many people in this room
are going to spend the next 30/40 years
of their lives trying to check the boxes
of the things that they're not as good at
and that you're going
to waste a (beep) load
of time and lose.